when you think about his position in the
world
most people i think were kind of just
like oh i was told not to like vladimir
putin so like you know bad guy right
if you start to learn about russia um
one of the books that probably has had
the most influence in terms of my view
of how some of the financial markets uh
was read notice bill browder's whole
book right um about the financial
markets and kind of american investors
russian investors he mentions putin in
there as like just like a competitor
basically in the market and the next
thing you know you know becomes
precedent
china seems to be like uh oh somebody
just put like more pieces on the chess
board and um
there's obviously the concern that like
china says like oh well russia can
invade ukraine and like you guys are
just going to sanction them like taiwan
come on over right yeah um and so like
whether that happens or not what remains
to be seen
but it does feel like those two
countries and they explicitly are
talking about it they want to get off
the us dollar they're starting to work
together more et cetera like is there a
world where we just get a bifurcation
and it's literally like
for better or worse terminology i'll say
like western world and eastern world and
basically in that bifurcation
literally there's circular there's two
separate circular economies uh or
insular economies that uh
maybe are like frenemies so maybe
there's some crossover or you know
selling of goods and services or
whatever but for the most part like
russia and china you know try to produce
and consume each other's goods and that
works and then the western world does
the same thing for themselves and
we don't have this like globalization
happening 100 percent i mean this has
been happening since 2014
yeah you know sort of uh luke groman
over at force for the trees is kind of a
expert on on a lot of these types of
topics um him and jeff snyder
and you know but they'll tell you both
of them you're really going back five
six seven years which is the world
splintered um jeff snyder would say hey
the world splintered in 2007 with the
breaking of you know sort of the euro
dollar network and and the credit
creation they're in or at least the the
former way of doing things and you know
lou garman would suggest that the sort
of global monetary system splintered in
2014 when the rest of the world really
stopped sort of sterilizing our debts
and deficits
by accumulating by stopping the
accumulation of of foreign exchange
reserves uh dollar denominated foreign
exchange reserves and so since 2014 i
would argue i'm probably more loose camp
on this
since 2014 we you know that that that
drive this sort of it's a it's a
it's a it's a realization amongst
emerging market and amongst other you
know kind of eastern if you will um
central banks to say hey look this
system isn't working for us if the cost
of capital is too high the availability
of capital is too scarce
we're not able to grow and meet our
development needs our goals to bring
folks out of poverty and things all that
good stuff quickly enough because the
supply and and price of dollar dominated
credit which is the global obviously
global most credits denominating dollars
globally it's too it's too hard to
obtain and so i think we're very much on
the pad we i've always thought we were
on a path towards bifurcated um monetary
systems it's unclear at the speed of
which um you know if that's all going to
happen at once and this these things
didn't happen like slowly slowly slowly
there's an event here an event there an
event here and then there's usually a
big event that sort of catalyzes the big
change
i'm not convinced that this is the big
event that catalyzes the big change
but i am convinced that both putin and
president xi of china are well aware
that this is the path that we're on and
they're going to take every liberty to
to to sort of perpetuate this because
ultimately it is a better outcome for
them which is to get off from underneath
the sort of the the the foot of the
dollar system so while we've been
talking uh putin's made some more
comments um
on fire
which is uh uh interesting because i
think exactly what you're saying
they've publicly talked about this right
i remember we pulled it up yesterday in
2018 i wrote a piece and it was like
poop is at a conference he basically was
like the us dollar system sucks it's too
expensive it's dangerous we got to get
off this thing like he wasn't hiding
anything right
right there in the conference uh but he
uh just said
russia remains part of global economy uh
we do not plan to damage the system that
we belong to uh and he says that his
partners or russia's partners should
understand that and should not push them
out from the system
so again we get into this
i'm going to call it gamesmanship that
might be too uh positive
of a word but i don't mean in a positive
way as much as uh maybe maybe
geopolitical chess is a better way to
describe it
where you get like what are they saying
what does it mean and then what are they
doing yeah
and it feels like this like constant
don't kick us out from the system we're
part of the system we we want to be part
of the uh us dollar based you know
financial system like it's all the right
things to say
but it seems like they positioned
themselves for a different world i have
a great analogy for this all right let's
hear it so good so uh my one of my
guilty pleasures of being uh a
engaged man now uh is watching
vanderpump rules on bravo with my fiance
and this is so reminiscent of jax being
a total [ __ ] to brittany because he
wants her to break up with him
so he's not the bad guy for breaking up
with her this like total angelic
sweetheart and finally he just snaps and
breaks up with her yup
like and so this to me it seems like
he's like kicking and screaming trying
to ho hopefully gets pushed out of the
system so he can finally say to china
hey look we need to you know advance
this um pretty aggressively right to me
i and one thing i also think in terms of
this bifurcation process
it's not going to come without
the loss of human life it's not going to
come without you know great financial
and economic costs right but it's it's
you know stasis is generally preferred
if you're thinking about you know
generating profits right you know you
have big change and it makes the whole
thing kind of slow down and grind to a
halt and so
there's a lot to lose uh for all parties
involved to make this transition but the
reality is that i think the folks that
are sort of
on the wrong side of the dollar system
if you owe russia china a lot of
emerging markets i think they're real
they're getting they've gotten to the
point where they're like there's a lot
to lose if we stay
right and so they're you know they're
kind of kicking and screaming hopefully
to get dumped so they can go you know
really transition at a more
expeditious pace that is that and more
importantly explain it to their citizens
right they gotta market this to chinese
citizens to russian citizens that say
look see they kicked us out of the swift
system the global dollar system we got a
transition you gotta deal with this pain
for now but we gotta make this
transition and i think they're looking
for political air cover to do that but
who knows if we'll give it to them at
this particular juncture again